heute geht es um milchzähne die kinder
sind zwischen drei und sechs jahre alt
darunter ihrer eigenen kinder und die
ihre angestellten die firmenchefin hat
vor sieben jahren den
betriebskindergarten gegründet nicht so
wie wir uns das vorgestellt hat und
nachdem einige verhandlungen auch mit
dem kindergarten hier partner bezüglich
öffnungszeiten konzept und
betreuungsschlüssel gescheitert war und
sich zu laufen für mich zu lange
hingezogen haben sagt mach mal selber
es gibt plätze für 74 kinder auch für
die ganz kleinen
nichts
aber jetzt ist er wieder da ilona riesen
bauer bringt ihre vierjährigen zwillinge
jeden morgen hierher
sie ist alleinerziehend steckt mitten in
der ausbildung zur industriekauffrau
wenn jetzt mal irgendwas sein sollte
dass ein kind krank wird oder was dann
bin ich ja gleich um die ecke
also bin ich innerhalb von zwei minuten
dann kann sagen gut gemacht
ich wohne hier auch hier das ist die
kleinstadt ergersheim in bayern
größter arbeitgeber die firma meter lang
sie stellt außenspiegel für lkw und
busse her jahresumsatz 105 millionen
euro
das unternehmen beschäftigt 1900
mitarbeiter viele im schichtbetrieb die
hälfte frauen
von 6 uhr 30 bis 18 uhr können sie ihre
kinder nebenan betreuen lassen
ilona riesen bauer die mutter der
zwillinge arbeitet in der
personalabteilung
sie kann ihre ausbildung in teilzeit
machen
in anderen unternehmen oft schwierig ich
könnte jetzt wahrscheinlich gar keine
ausbildung machen den passenden
kindergarten dann zu finden das wäre
sehr schwierig also wie gesagt weil ja
auch manche kindergärten eben man muss
die kinder mittags abholen und das kaum
möglich so susanne lang ist das thema
kinderbetreuung ein persönliches
anliegen
angefangen hat die unternehmerin mit
einer ferienbetreuung dann das angebot
ausgebaut
heute beschäftigt sie 28 erzieherinnen
mit einer anständigen kinderbetreuung
habe ich natürlich dass die möglichkeit
fachkräfte an uns zu binden und auch die
möglichkeit jungen qualifizierten frauen
die sich sonst am arbeitsmarkt schwer
tun weil sie eben kleine kinder haben
oder in der familienplanung sind oder
die kinder im schulalter sind probleme
stelle zu finden
einen sechsstelligen betrag hat sie in
den ausbau der betreuungsplätze
investiert sie findet in deutschland
habe es junge mütter schwer
die mütter können es nur falsch laufen
gehen die arbeiten dann kümmern sie sich
nicht um die kinder
da gehen sie nicht arbeiten da sitzen
sie nur zu hause und haben wenig zu tun
und die wahrheit liegt irgendwo
dazwischen wichtig ist wir brauchen die
qualitative betreuung für die kinder
denn das ist unsere zukunft angeht so
sind immer auch auf die unplugged
umsonst ist der kindergarten nicht als
auszubildende zeit in monaco bauer pro
monat rund 50 euro dazu
im sommer ist sie mit der lehre fertig
wenn alles glatt läuft wird sie
übernommen